President Trump said he felt vindicated
after Israel's prime minister said
Monday Iran lied about its nuclear
intentions but today the United Nations
nuclear agency did not back that up and
late this afternoon former Secretary of
State John Kerry tweeted that every
detail Netanyahu presented yesterday was
why the world came together to negotiate
the nuclear agreement adding quote blow
up the deal and you're back there
tomorrow
correspondent Connor Powell reports
tonight on the conflicting reports as
the deadline looms for President Trump
to decide whether to re-up the nuclear
deal Israeli Prime Minister Benjamin
Netanyahu continued his campaign to
convince President Trump to scrap the
Iran nuclear deal making the rounds on
cable news this morning telling Fox and
Friends Iran is trying to quote
bamboozle the entire world by refusing
to disclose its previous nuclear
ambitions when they did the nuclear deal
with Iran it was promised its
implementation was premise taun the fact
that Iran would come clean and it would
admit if it had any nuclear weapons
program they didn't come clean they lied
however nan yahoos claimed that Iran is
currently in violation of the deal that
can R is being widely disputed Tehran
denies the accusation insisting it's in
full compliance and only a month ago
Israel's own military chief of staff
general Eisen Cote said at this point we
are not identifying any violations of
the jcpoa while Frances foreign ministry
said European leaders have known about
Iran's non civilian nuclear activities
since 2002 which is consistent with the
2011 US National Intelligence Estimate
which laid out Iran's nuclear program
from the early 2000s crucially the
International Atomic Energy Agency which
is responsible for the inspections in
Iran said today there is no evidence
Tehran has reconstituted its nuclear
program the jcpoa the nuclear agreement
is based not on
sumption of good faith or trust is based
on concrete commitments verification
mechanisms and a very strict monitoring
of facts done by the IAA the IAS
released ten reports certifying that
Iran has fully complied with its
commitments during his media round today
Netanyahu is also asked about Israel's
nuclear capabilities and was asked if
Iran's disclosure is so important why
won't Israel disclose its own nuclear
program Netanyahu refused to answer
whether or not Israel had a nuclear
weapon insisting this isn't about Israel
but Iran Brett Carter pal in our Middle
East newsroom counter Thanks